EVAN CAROTHERS: Docalytics
is a technology platform
for sales and marketing
professionals.
And we allow them to track
metrics and engagement
around their
downloadable content.
So things like white papers,
case studies, ebooks.
We give them insight into how
that content is getting engaged
to sell the market
more effectively.
Start-up weekend,
me and Ryan worked
tirelessly for over a
year, nights and weekends,
in our basement to get
the product to market.
Entirely bootstrapped and
founder-funded for a long time.
We ended up participating
in an accelerator program
this last summer in
Wisconsin called gener8tor.
So that gave us some
initial seed funding
to get through that
accelerator program
as we got our product
completely into the marketplace.
And from there,
we're just continuing
to grow our customer base.
And we raised just over $500,000
of what we're calling a Series
A to get us to
that next milestone
where we can hope to raise the
largest Series A investment.
It's beautiful to be a
technologist because it's fun
to work on things that
are difficult problems
and stuff that you know is going
to have a change in the world
market.
So we bootstrapped because it
was a smart financial decision
for the company initially,
but also because we're
really passionate
about what we're doing,
and it made sense to get our
product scalable strongly
in the market before we
went to raise any money.
STEVE PECK: Yeah.
And what I would add
to that is that it
was a conscious decision
to have something
to offer in the
marketplace and get
some early traction and early
wins with some key accounts
so that when we did go
to find that funding
it was an easier process
because we already
had use cases and key
customers to reference.